well that just you know it's the reason
that people should read the book we're
still here because there are Indians all
around us all among us but they don't
wear their traditional regalia and their
feathers to work or out to the grocery
store you know they are still here mi
t--'s John Pearman describes the
disintegration of American culture and
the opinion of Americans abroad in his
book 100 ways America is screwing up the
world he spoke about it recently at
politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC for about an hour
have you ever watched the news and
thought about the state of the world and
asked yourself how many ways is America
screwing up the world 5 10 maybe 20
well according to tonight's author John
Chairman executive director of MIT
Center for International Studies there
are a hundred ways or more perhaps that
America is screwing up the world thanks
from the list here a few that caught my
eye altering the Earth's climate
that's way number one consumerism
that's way number 45 Las Vegas way 85
nuclear weapons way 18 the attack on
science way 46 and my favorite Mel
Gibson he is way 64
to tell us more about how America is
screwing up the world please help me
welcome John chairman thank you very
much Mel Gibson I got lucky with Mel I
handed in the manuscript in January and
then although it wasn't about him being
drunk and disorderly anti-semitic yes
we'll get to that later very nice to be
here back in Washington I lived in
Washington for ten years which is why I
have a chapter on Washington I don't
know if any of you have seen it I want
to apologize for it in advance if any of
you actually like living here but I like
living here so it's nice to be back and
I see a lot of friends here and family
and people who were living in the same
building and on a board and so on and so
forth it's it's like a homecoming so
thank you for coming I'm going to speak
about a couple of themes in the book
which I wrote at the behest of the
publisher an unusual circumstance for
policy wonks and academics who can
barely get the ear of a publisher most
of the time but this particular
publisher HarperCollins called me one
day and asked me if I wanted to write
this book or would I'd like to discuss
it and I thought it was a provocative
title mm-hmm sail these
attention-getting but it did give me an
opportunity and I was keen to do it
because of this opportunity to to
discuss or to to really start an
argument an argument about the u.s. role
in the world something that we tend to
bring up in our public discourse only
when something really goes wrong like
Iraq for example I'll come back to that
too
but rarely do we examine with much care
or in my case some amusement and some
irony the the way that America is seen
in the world and what kinds of impacts
we actually have this is a big bold
dynamic country largest economy in the
world popular culture that is just
consumed avidly everywhere in the world
and yet I think most Americans are not
really aware of how much these things
affect other people and so that's the
place I started from but I found myself
as I as I built the hundred ways built
the list and wrote the chapters I found
myself sort of alternating between about
four different categories one was
environmental destruction I concentrated
a lot on this it's the it's the number
one way altering the earth which is
about climate change because these kinds
of activities toxic waste dumping
pesticides etc etc are are ways that
that have been unfolding for many years
they're not really
they are partisan issues but they've
happened under both Democrats and
Republicans without adequate remedy and
there are things that are going to
affect us affect Americans and the rest
of the world for many many years to come
so that was that was the first category
the second one was economics and
economics is hard to write in a popular
way so I didn't do a lot with that but I
did write a bit of bad things like our
policies in the third world that in
which we demand the government's
Institute privatization and
marketization as it's called which has
had I think in many places catastrophic
results the third category would be
politics
or politics by other means as we can say
it politely which is of course war
interventions dictators support their of
problems with upholding standards of
human rights and so on quite a few of
those I specialized at MIT and have for
some years and global security issues
and I really had to restrain myself from
writing more about these kinds of topics
but I did so by by taking up themes in
the in the fourth category which is
culture and I had a lot of fun with
those things like Hollywood violence
that's actually the Mel Gibson chapter
consumerism television
Paris Hilton another enduring icon of
America the self-help movement the New
Age movement things like that the Paris
Hilton chapter is kind of an interesting
one because it illustrates how how
something that really began is kind of a
meant to be just sort of amusing and to
say you know rather obvious things about
about pop culture that you know here's
this this icon of American pop culture
who as everyone has said countless times
is famous for being famous and you know
as a celebrity without talent and so on
all of which may be true but as I as I
got into it I realized that there's
there's actually serious diseases that
are associated with celebrity worship a
pair of social diseases what it's called
and this is particularly problematic for
young women and girls teenage girls who
begin to identify so strongly with a
celebrity or more than one they believe
that they know the celebrity and they
stop forming actual relationships with
other people
serious issue and that happened to me a
lot while I was writing this book and it
was particularly fun to do with these
cultural topics which I don't claim to
be expert on but but I have often
amusing sort of beginnings in these
chapters but but then lead to more
serious points and of course the larger
point being that America is is not only
doing this to itself in some important
ways but is spreading these things out
into the rest of the world I would
include in the cultural thing although
it it sort of moves over into into
politics as well the the evangelical
movements for example in this in this
case it's not just incidental that it's
spreading around the world it's an
intentional policy of finding as one
evangelical website says finding the
lost souls of the world and converting
them to Christianity and they described
India as a lost continent of of a
billion a billion lost souls which I
thought is the most astonishing kind of
conjecture or assertion of an imperial
vision that you could that you could
look at an ancient religion like this as
as representing lost souls that need to
be converted now of course not all
cultural things not all political things
not even economic policy is
intentionally being spread around the
world like this a lot of it is is
unintentional and this is where we get
into the three what I would say three
sort of themes that are threads of ideas
that work their way through the book as
I said at the outset the Americans are
largely oblivious to the to the to the
depth and the
breath of this effect of the effect of
any and all of these things and
therefore bad guys can get away with bad
policies all the time I have a friend
who here in Washington who used to work
on the hill and I think he used to call
there's certain legislation that they
would call something like 3 a.m.
legislation so I can't remember exactly
what the phrase was but by that he meant
you know things that happen in the
middle of the night when nobody's paying
attention basically now that's that way
all the time you know because we're so
distracted by the war on terror such as
it is something we can discuss in the
Q&A on the war in Iraq the and and these
kind of you know Hollywood distractions
of various kinds that it's very hard to
focus in the public discourse and and
and consciousness on on things that
matter a second theme is that many of
the trends we see in politics and
culture extol individualism at the
expense of public action and public
goods as I look through the list and and
and of course reread countless times my
own writing I realized that I kept
coming back to a couple of themes one of
which was how you know the self you can
see it in some of the trivial things
like self-help movement in and the in
the New Age and and things of that kind
television and you can see it in larger
policy issues the ideology of
marketization for example the way that
we create trade relations the American
dream I have a chapter on that this is
all about individual effort individual
getting ahead material acquisitiveness
to some extent this is the ideology
that has I think undercut the the
long-standing notion of solidarity of
community of solving problems together
of of taking public discourse in public
action
seriously the sort of the highest good
of society and of governance and both of
these things
the obliviousness the individualism lead
to what I would call unsustainable
behavior that is it's not just
unsustainable in you know Bush's
recklessness in in in the Middle East it
also has to do with this the the our
incapacity there the incapacity of the
earth to sustain the kind of lifestyles
that Americans even middle-class
Americans I don't mean just wealthy
Americans although I do have a chapter
on the filthy rich that I think you'll
enjoy the middle class Americans have
have adopted you know everything from
SUVs to - you know McMansions to
commuting great distances to other
things many of which of course have to
do with oil dependency but it's it's
it's it's bigger than that it's a much
deeper problem of both obliviousness to
the rest of the world and its needs and
a kind of individualism that says why
should I care why why should I sell my
SUV when I get so much enjoyment out of
it well the reason is because SUVs are
bad for the rest of the earth and other
reasons as well but but it's but there's
no I think there's much less of a kind
of a social consciousness about these
things in agreement that the that that
that personal responsibility is
important to the future of this country
and end to the rest of the world so
finally then back to the question why
why a hundred ways
in the end I think that the the role of
of criticism in our culture is also
something that has declined at least
toleration for criticism has declined
along with the rise of the right wing in
this country I was on I've been doing a
lot of radio shows as one has want to do
in this book writing business and I was
on Michael Medved show the other day now
this is an experience in itself but I
don't know how many of you know Michael
who Michael Medved is but he's made his
bones as a film critic and now is
basically another right wing talk show
host and the the vitriolic denunciation
of me by his listeners and by him in
different ways for having the temerity
to write a book with this title none of
them had read the book of course was was
really palpable I mean it was I expected
it so I wasn't I wasn't shocked or upset
by it but but it was quite remarkable
how you get the same kind of you know
phrases like why don't you go live in
China I used to be in Russia and now
it's China I don't know what that says
about they didn't say Cuba but but but I
mean one thing after another you know
you're living in an ivory tower oh
you're in Cambridge of course that's the
way you feel and so on I felt like
answering him in French but my French
isn't good enough so I couldn't do it
but anyway what what my point here is
that is that even the simple role of
criticism and a lot of the book is meant
to be just tongue and cheek and and and
a lot of it is is actually criticizing
liberals and and sort of liberal
shibboleths it's not all going in one
direction I have a chapter on there
for example which has already got me
into some trouble and and other things
gangster rap Paris Hilton etc but what I
try to explain when I'm given a chance
is that I think that this is sort of
like tough love for America right I mean
this is this is what everybody loves
this idea of tough love you know the
principal in Harlem the principal in
South East who gives us students tough
love and this changes their lives well
you know this is what I'm trying to do
tough love for all of America you see my
heart is big enough for all of America
which worries my doctors but but
ultimately I think that this is really
this kind of book not the book
specifically but the spirit of criticism
the spirit of taking your country
seriously the issues seriously and
looking at them with your eyes wide open
is ultimately an act of citizenship of
good citizenship and we should all be
good citizens right I mean we should all
be informed we should all be active we
should all be alert to things that we're
doing wrong as a country or a community
a city what-have-you and we should be
empowered to say so empowered in the
sense of being able to to engage in this
debate to start an argument as I said at
the at the beginning without being
dismissed as being an agent of who's
left Fidel Castro man
and ultimately what I I suggest at the
end of the book I have a chapter about
the 10 things America does right and in
some ways this chapter was simply meant
to assure the readers that I was capable
of complimenting the United States but I
had a had another purpose in this and
that was to was to say there are things
that America does right I mean we all
know that and there's a lot of
cheerleading for that kind of thing but
I wanted to set a marker for what I
think these things are and to say and
and they're things like fairness and and
you know educational excellence and and
immigration and and other things not all
of which are perfectly embodied in our
politics but I think the in the long in
the long view they are but but the
baseline here and I'll finish with this
is that the we should be able to
articulate
what we think these principles are as a
country and if we don't live up to them
then we should say that we don't live up
to them and that's what this book is
really about it's about principles of
action of fairness of equity in the
world of sustainable you know trying to
create a sustainable environment and
lifestyle about about diplomacy over
military action as a leading edge of
foreign policy of quality and common
sense in in pop culture and so on and if
we do those things if we are just
sensible and and loyal to our own
principles I think that writing a book
like this in the future would be much
more difficult to do thank you
so we'll take some questions and
comments yeah come to the microphone
please yes I wanted to ask you a few
questions about one topic are you
familiar with Noam Chomsky okay my
colleague ok so I wanted to add spirit
or yeah I wanted to ask you how what's
his how do the students and the faculty
at MIT view him he is a professor of
linguistics and also a professor of
philosophy so what's his a concern in
philosophy I mean what did he he study
in particular in philosophy because he
does act as as a kind of political
philosopher it seems to me which is a
very interesting topic and I was
wondering you know what your view is as
well of Noam Chomsky if you could just
elaborate on on him a little well I
can't speak for what his philosophy is
you know he made his reputation as as a
linguist and a revolution in linguistics
I should say and in that sense he is he
is much honored and I think in in the
academic world and at MIT he doesn't
teach any longer at MIT as some PhD
students but so his his presence around
campus is probably less than it was some
years ago I think the Chomsky I was
actually reading about a year or so ago
I was reading some of his his work
around Vietnam because I was interested
in the group of dissidents including
Howard Zinn was wrote the foreword to my
book this group of dissidents and how
how was that they were framing
debate over Vietnam early in the
conflict 64 65 66 before it became
unpopular and Chomsky's writings were
really they're quite interesting you
should go back and look at them I think
there's some collected there's a you
know a portable Chomsky or something
like that there's a couple of
collections of his of his work that are
that are current in print and he had a
capacity for doing what I was talking
about earlier which was to juxtapose
America's ideals against its actions
particularly of course in Southeast Asia
and he was very thorough in his in his
in his research and as and his
exposition and and and this of course
was I think influential certainly for
the large campus movement and the war at
that time since that time he's gotten
into some hot water about Israel and
Palestinians although I don't really
know that the details of that but on
some other issues like East Timor he was
he was one of the first people in this
country to point out the Indonesian
repression in East Timor he's
instrumental in getting international
action on that so for that reason alone
and his opposition to Vietnam not to
mention his academic work I think he is
someone to be celebrated peculiar twist
of fate he and I are both have books
being prosecuted by the Turkish
government right now I wrote a book ten
years ago called spoils of war which was
about the American relationship with
Turkey and their war against the Kurds
or the civil war in Turkey and how we
were supplying arms to them and so on
and it is it was translated in Turkish
and and soon after that the publisher
was brought up on charges of
insulting the state insulting the
military insulting Ataturk and a long
list of things of course those are
things that I did but I'm not going back
to Turkey to stand trial so
unfortunately the publisher is in my
stead but Chomsky's in the same boat and
has been before with the same publisher
so we've been working a little bit on
together on on statements of solidarity
with with the publisher yes looks like a
fun book and it looks like it's very
balanced and I love the fact you
included the 10 things that America does
right I agree with all of them I'm glad
you included diversity in the good
things and multiculturalism as one of
the annoying things because I I find
that too and I think it's important to
make a distinction but in that way among
your 10 I also feel there's a real
inherent conflict in too and I think a
lot of good intention people are feeling
this conflict and I just wanted you to
clear it up a little bit it's between
the rule of law which I just think is
absolutely vital and I think one of
these and a lot of people come to this
country is because they the people we
have a strong rule of law but obviously
you don't include immigration law is one
of those because you also say open doors
and that seems to me like you're taking
more of a libertarian view of
immigration that it's an open border
sort of situation so I just wanted you
to clear that up because I think a lot
of people are very conflicted about that
we believe in diversity we believe in
our immigration but when it comes to
immigration law we're having a real
trouble saying you know we have it and
that means some people can come in and
some people can't and we have a long we
have to enforce it so how do you deal
with that well good question
I hope not all the questions are going
to be this difficult to answer
on the rule of law what I really was
really talking about there was not so
much specific applications but but
generally that America is always prided
itself on the you know nation of laws
not men and that sort of thing which you
know largely is true and of course there
are lots and lots of things that one
could point to including you know right
now the Bush administration's sort of
stretching things on a lot of in a lot
of areas having to do mainly with with
national security and say oh no no no no
this is not the rule of law well I think
the the overall drift of the American
experience has been to uphold the rule
of law in in in you know in a fairly
consistent fashion I mean you know
sometimes the laws haven't been very
good you know we went for many many
years in which segregation and other
kinds of racial discrimination was legal
essentially and sometimes the Supreme
Court would rule in such ways that would
make owners things legal so it's you
know it's a mixed record to be sure but
I think that it's a powerful symbol for
a world in which in which law is often
simply a an instrument of state power in
a way that has no independent life of
its own and and so on so I that was
basically what I was driving it there
the immigration issue is an interesting
one I I I got you know lucky with Mel
Gibson I got a little bit unlucky with
the immigration debate because that
flared up right after I finished this
book and I think I would have taken it
up a little bit more earnestly had I
written a book later it is true that I'm
not for perfectly open board I mean
totally open borders I think there do
need to be laws and enforced laws about
who comes in who gets legal status and
so on
the problem is and always has been with
the so-called illegal immigration
problem
is that we have often as a country we've
often been trying to solve a problem
that initially didn't really exist in
other words going back to the 50s 60s
70s even into the 80s most Mexican
immigration we're talking mainly about
Mexican immigration Mexican workers
coming across the border would work as
seasonal agricultural workers and then
they would go back to Mexico and this
was viewed as actually a very good
solution to labor shortages in certain
sectors not just agriculture but a few
other things what happened was in in
starting in the 1980s that that laws
began to be passed that made it harder
for them to get across the border more
Border Patrol's
fences in some places around San Diego
for example and and these actions even
though it did not reduce the actual flow
of immigrants into this country of
illegal immigrants it raised the costs
of coming into the United States
significantly for these people and so
the result of that was that they tended
to stay longer and then began to bring
their families because they knew they
were going to stay longer so in other
words a so-called solution to this
problem which was never really a problem
to begin with actually created a much
larger problem instead of having a
temporary workforce which satisfied just
about everybody's needs you now have
people coming in and staying for much
longer periods of time essentially
permanent or semi-permanent and illegal
and that has you know lots of issues for
their access to health care the cost of
health care particularly in in border
towns education and so on so I think
that we were foolish in the first place
to accede to a kind of a political
impulse to to tag immigrants as a
problem when in fact they were not I
won't say that there's
problems associated with it because
there are problems for the border towns
they should get more federal aid there
should be there ways to deal with that
but to build a fence which is basically
what is being proposed now and much
greater border control is is a very
severe reaction probably one that won't
work and a bad symbol besides I think
it's telling I'll just I'll stop here I
think it's telling that this issue
flared up so dramatically in the midst
of the Iraq war and and and and the
sharp decline of US public support for
the Iraq war which is a historical
pattern about immigration that goes back
to the beginning of the 20th century
when the nation is under national stress
for one reason or another economic
stress national security stress
something else immigrants are often
tagged as being a problem and it's a
diversionary tactic by demagogic
politicians there is not an immigration
problem in this country not a big one I
know you disagree you're shaking your
head that's your right but I would argue
this right down to the last moment thank
you for your question though hi my
question is gonna be simple and probably
simplistic but I wanted to ask you about
I read a book called a while ago called
the confessions of an economic hitman a
very disturbing book for me anyway it
talks and waffle hot about an America
that I knew was there but I guess didn't
want to admit that I know was there was
there in South Africa it's there in a
lot of places and I was thinking that if
we didn't have this type of policy and
didn't support this type of behavior
which has all kinds of economic benefits
for our country maybe we would have less
problems with the rest of the world
including immigration I'm aware of the
book I haven't read it I actually
someone sent it to me and I started to
read a little bit and I and I had the
problem I had with it was that there's
no way to verify what this guy is saying
basically
I mean it's a real problem you know I
mean he could be right in which case I
mean he could be telling the truth in
which case it's really from what I
understand of the book a horrifying
thing but it's it's really hard to know
how to take this I know it's getting a
lot of play now I should probably should
probably read it but it is you know it's
about a lot of clandestine ugly stuff
that's been going on at the behest of
the US government and corporations and
so on but I'm not quite sure I'm
convinced but I think we have to believe
some of it anyway yeah the problem is
which much bits to believe in which it's
not I used to travel to South Africa
with my husband and we were having we
were not dealing with apartheid or the
South African government he worked for a
huge mining company that did business
all the time with South Africa and did
all kinds of incredible things in
Botswana and Namibia starvation people
were wiped out all this gonna so I
believe I'm sure there's there's a lot
of nasty things that happened there's no
question yeah thank you thank you to
follow up on this lady's comment or her
I mean if you go back and look at the
history of America there's a lot of
stuff they're dealing with Native
Americans dealing with Africans dealing
with Mexicans and so forth so it it's to
the point where you tend to almost
believe those books rather than deny
them and almost somebody has to come up
and show you the denial if you realize
the history ok the points are this one a
lot of what's done in the name of
America is in American corporations so I
don't like the fact that we always label
things America when a lot of it is our
corporate behavior the point that I'm
gonna address to you to ask you about is
that the awareness and your your book
would probably raise the awareness but
the awareness is actually lagging behind
the events right now in the world in
other words world events and things are
happening so rapidly
getting embroiled in these wars and so
forth that the public is so far behind
in the realization of what's going on
what do you expect I mean your effort to
bring these things to the surface is
good but the fact of the matter is the
events now are surpassing the awareness
of the leadership - and we're we're
gonna suffer and the final thing is it's
not just America I mean we're talking to
some degree about human nature I mean
many of the empires have done similar
type things
ya know penis is not a comparative thing
I mean I in fact I say somewhere that
it's not other people when you have when
you're head of other people to take
advantage of that so well yeah yes and
no I guess you know one hopes that the
global norms have changed in such a way
that it's less acceptable to treat
people badly even if you're powerful but
I do point out that it's you know this
is not saying that America is the worst
country or anything like that it's is
the British and Soviets and you know all
kinds have lots to answer for there's no
question about that but you know I'm an
American we're here I'm gonna write
about America and of course we are now
the you know the hyper power or whatever
the current phrases you know your your
your question about what can be done
sort of thing is what how do the events
throughout running our ability to govern
I think is a very interesting point I
mean I want to speak to that rather than
try to explain what I think can be done
alternatively I do have I should say I
do have a website John Chairman calm in
which I have the main reason for making
the website was to have references for
the book because of course we just want
to have footnotes in this book that
would be just too academic looking so
and in those references I have links to
lots and lots of organizations that are
working on the problems that I'm
identifying so there is you know people
do work on
these things and some work on them very
effectively and I'm sure there are many
people here tonight at work in some of
those organizations so it's it's not
hopeless but what your comment about
events sort of outrunning our ability to
control or govern there is a very good
example and we haven't talked about it
yet and that is of course Iraq and I
think it does need to be said because
the the reasons for going into Iraq and
pursuing it the way it's been pursued
really bring together all kinds of the
issues that I talked about in this book
and I do threat a lot about Iraq
throughout the book I mean petroleum
dependency we you know clearly would not
be in Iraq if it were not for its oil
reserves the sort of cultural
insensitivities the scene the entire
world as a as a nail and and we have a
hammer and that sort of thing and now in
Iraq we see that events have gotten out
of our capacity to control them to
govern them there literally is no good
solution now for Iraq maybe there never
was but at least the massive amount of
killing and mayhem that has occurred
since March of 2003 would not have taken
place had we not invaded and there may
have been other ways to deal in fact
there were other ways to deal with
Saddam Hussein as Thomas Rick's points
out in his excellent new book called
fiasco that the you know the sanctions
and we the sanctions had their problems
too but sanctions that weakened him the
Clinton action in in 98 had weakened him
and so on he was a wounded wounded
leader but in any case my point here is
that through a certain amount of
arrogance through a certain kind of
mindset about our role in the world we
were led into this fiasco that is going
to have impacts in that region for years
and years and years to come
one of one of my chapters is about the
Reagan doctrine which surprisingly
enough has gotten very little treatment
after the fact either academic or more
popular writing yet here was here was an
innovation so to speak of Ronald Reagan
while he was president to unseat
Communists governments or you know
sympathetic to communism through
supporting guerrilla movements the you
know exhibit a was Afghanistan you know
what can you say about the results of
that of that initiative
well what came out of Afghanistan among
other things was the Taliban and al
Qaeda and a number of other things now
even now the poppy production is back to
record levels there the heroin suppliers
of the world and so on and so forth a
catastrophe for the people of that
region all done for you know a set of
ideological beliefs Cambodia another
example Angola a million people dead
Mozambique chameleon people did
Nicaragua now a you know beleaguered by
drug running and and poverty and so on I
mean one colossal disaster after another
and we're doing it again in Iraq and
part of it is we don't have historical
memory we don't have public debates
about these things it's their boat into
to criticize Reagan's why spend a lot of
time talking about Reagan the the idea
that the United States caused you know
al-qaeda or or you know drug running in
Central America or what-have-you
which of course is too simplistic but
nevertheless is something that we should
be able to discuss especially when we're
facing
these as major problems a drug problem
terrorism problem and so on so my point
here a little bit off your question but
is to say that yes events often get out
of control from what is seemingly
intended and what we need are better and
better
you know citizens better and better ways
to engage on these issues and to hold
the government accountable and
corporations accountable two sets of
standards that that promote stability
and and and peace and all the other
things that we all say were in favor of
I was fascinated how much Christianity I
found in your book I see you have the
chapters on the puritanical ethic and on
Mel Gibson on Christmas and then a most
Christian nation what would Jesus say
you seem to be very well versed in the
Gospels and particularly the Sermon on
the Mount
hallelujah brother I mean so I was
curious about your I assume you have
some kind of Christian background or I
do and then I and then I was very
encouraged by you you do in the book
optimistically about the ten things
America does right in the world you end
with human rights and that does seem to
be something that Christians Jews
agnostics atheists left and right they
they do seem to be in agreement with and
you know I don't see much of the rest of
the world standing up in the way that
Americans do well the human rights issue
is is complicated because we have been
in many ways the principal promoter of
human rights at least among major
nations for many many years but it's
been done very imperfectly and it's been
done imperfectly I think because other
other interests so-called security
interests usually where economic
interests tend to trump our concern for
human rights when it really comes down
to a specific place so for example you
can remember the the
the period of the the 1970s when Jimmy
Carter was president he was the human
rights president right and one of the
places that human rights might have been
applied more rigorously and Senator
Kennedy and others did try to do this
through Senate resolutions was in Iran
and and Iran is a very good example of a
place where we turned a blind eye for
many many years in fact installed the
repressive regime in 1953 that repressed
human rights in this very large very
important Islamic country and not only
supported the Shah but helped him
suppress things like you know the left
and and others who might have given some
political pluralism and legitimacy to
the regime and of course it all
collapsed catastrophic ly with the with
the rise of the Islamic Revolution which
of course has turned into a rather
repressive mess and here we are at
loggerheads again that's an example of
where human rights were not promoted in
a steady consistent realistic way inside
Iran by the United States and and the
results have been a disaster and and
that has been true in a lot of countries
and that's where the contradiction comes
in but we do stand for human rights in
our constitution or Bill of Rights and
in much of our our rhetoric and and in
some of the actions and certainly I
think in terms of citizen action in NGOs
civil society we've been very strong on
that score so I think it is a good value
to hang on to and it's something that we
have to do better in implementing hello
I'm curious question about 9/11 I have
the impression that American if I may
put it this way American rules of
engagement with the rest of the world
changed
as a result of 9/11 and then I wonder if
you could reflect on what have been the
appropriate responses thus far would
have been inappropriate responses by the
American government
visa vie responding to 911 in the five
years well I guess the simplest way I
can answer that it's a complicated
question because there's so many
responses and in so many places but
let's look at what happened just two
weeks ago with you with the arrests or
the disruption of this alleged plot to
blow up airliners in London I think what
what this tells us and other less
sensational episodes particularly in
Europe is that is that law enforcement
very well-organized
alert law enforcement legal surveillance
developing human contact you know human
intelligence cooperation between
different intelligence agencies and
police and intelligence and so on can in
fact prevent some of the worst things
from happening there been a lot of
arrests in in Europe of what appear to
be some bad guys and if we could develop
the same relationships that we have
among Europeans in to some extent the
United States with countries in the
region where we think much of this is
coming from Pakistan among them but not
exclusively so we would probably do
pretty well in containing the containing
or even reversing the the the global
jihad movement which after all could be
a temporary thing
and we've seen other things like this in
the past that peter out what is the
wrong policy for this is the war in Iraq
I mean what we know of the Madrid
bombers a local group not connected to
al-qaeda what we know of the London
train bombers of the
year ago a local group not apparently
connected to al-qaeda is that you know
these are angry guys angry for what
reasons hard to say you know lots of
complex accounts on this but what is
clear is that the trigger
for their violence was their anger about
Iraq more than anything else now these
are emblematic of a much larger problem
of the creation of politically vial of
reasons for people in Saudi Arabia in
Iraq in in you know in Jordan in Egypt
and so on to become to cross a threshold
from being simply angry to being violent
and angry now fortunately not that many
have there are in Iraq but of course
they're fighting a war there and the
question is whether or not they will
then continue as some from the Afghan
cohort did after 1990 if they will
continue as a as a kind of a the new al
Qaeda that is clearly the wrong way to
deal with the war on terror and I and I
find it particularly objectionable that
President Bush yesterday and Vice
President Cheney and others in the
Republican Party and Fox News redundant
to say that of course but are saying
that oh you Democrats don't get it you
don't understand that Iraq is the front
of the war against terrorism
no we do understand that it's in front
of the war against terrorism you created
it you made this happen and that's why
you should not be in power and and it
would be a real shame and a real I think
of a very clear example of of the
failure of our public debate if if that
argument prevails for a long period of
time so I think you know law enforcement
you know it's kind of a mundane answer
but it works
and war not so good
I mean look at Lebanon no you know
what's you think that Hezbollah is
popular in Lebanon yes a lot more
popular than they were in June same
thing microcosm of what's going on in
Iraq and believe me in Israel today
there is a very fervent debate about
this
I mean bitterly you know spirited debate
about this and Israel can do that can
have that debate and we can't that's
amazing was the response in Afghanistan
appropriate at the time well you know I
think given the trauma that 9/11 caused
to the United States it would have been
very hard not to do something in
Afghanistan and what the options are you
know this is one of the problems we have
is critics is we don't really know what
the options are we don't know what the
intelligence tells us we don't know what
you know who's where who's doing what
and so on because it just it rarely
comes to light and certainly not in a
timely way were there alternatives I
just you know it's it's just a very
difficult question to answer you recall
that when they set out to in in in
October of 2001 in Afghanistan the the
the reason for going in was not to
overthrow the Taliban that that was an
afterthought or at least publicly it was
an afterthought and it came when they
were having difficulty achieving their
strategic objectives so that was a very
improvised operation which of course has
only partially succeeded and I think the
Afghanistan situation we won't know for
a few years really what the results are
thank you for a very interesting book i
justö wonder do we have in the United
States a niche to go around and save all
damsels in distress' and then eh to
intervene and set things aright for
example a few years back the Library of
Congress prepared a report for Congress
which outlined our military
interventions abroad from the beginning
of our history 236 now if we count Iraq
and Afghanistan that would be 238 in
addition of those 46 of them have been
in Central America so I just wonder this
is B from our history the first one was
of course in the shores of Tripoli
punishing the Barbary pirates after we
left they resumed their piracy only
Napoleon end of that for example in 53:8
the question is do we have an itch are
we sort of cursed by an itch to set
things aright all over the world at all
times from the very beginning of our
independence in 1853 we enforced Japan
to open in 1898 we forced we took over
the Philippines which were halfway
around the world yeah by the way I'm a
retired military I was in the army from
1942 to 1970 I just wonder is what
drives us to always say these 238 times
to intervene militarily well I think
most of them are it's a good question
and it's not an easy one to answer I
think that there are you know there's
there's a very sort of limited answer in
the sense of it not being very grandiose
and that is we we've intervened a lot to
protect what we consider to be our
interests economic interests
national security interests and and so
on very often misguided but nevertheless
there were those rationales but there
does seem to be more broadly speaking to
your question the the idea of American
exceptionalism that we have we do have a
mission you know there is a there's a
lot of Christian sort of metaphor or
imagery that goes along with discussing
America's role in the world by many
people it's sort of unconsciously you
know there are many liberals who are
still you know in favor of you know the
good hegemon you know that we're we're
strong we're powerful we should use our
military might to do good in fact many
of the liberal Hawks I write about this
in the book Michael Ignatieff
Christopher Hitchens etc Fred Hyde who's
still remarkably as the editor of the
editorial page of the Washington Post
yeah you know they promoted this notion
that yes we're gonna go protect human
rights we're gonna get rid of this
monster and so on without coming to
terms I think as many of us did
beforehand that once you start a war you
don't know what's going to happen and
unintended consequences ensue so you
know it's not just a you know a
Shibboleth of the right it's not not
just about interest there is something
about you know sort of internationalism
of you know were the chosen people to do
these things and it's not it's a hard
myth to to get rid of it's very self
gratifying to think that that's the
country we live in
I was wondering when you entered the
human rights question you weren't
mentioned in Guantanamo and I'm from
Austria and I remember you are we had a
huge discussion about this because it
happened on American territory and so I
was wondering because um so we don't
have the last impression it's not
positive that's that's why it was really
and I don't know so yeah well you know
the Guantanamo I think is outrageous to
think that a bunch of fighters you pick
up in Afghanistan in a war you know we
invaded after all maybe for good reasons
but we invaded and we pick up a bunch of
fighters and take them off to this
island under no real legal jurisdiction
and hold them for all these years
thinking that's and you know the excuses
they're terrorists they're going to give
us information etc I mean how valuable
can the information they give us now be
just from a practical standpoint quite
apart from the moral or legal questions
associated with this I mean it's just
it's ridiculous and it came to mind
again during the the debate that started
with this London bombing plot there was
the one of the first right-wing
responses on on Hannity and Colmes I
think was I watch these programs I have
to it's like a sore tooth you know you
can't keep your tongue off of it but you
always want to know what Karl Rove was
thinking every morning and that that's
where you find out one of the first
things they said was oh you know the
British have all these laws or lack of
laws that allow them to do all kinds of
things that we can't do like detain
detaining
a suspect for 28 days well we've been
detaining people in Guantanamo for three
years five years what am I saying five
years we've had we you know we picked up
thousands of American Muslims or Muslims
living in America some some of them
citizens some of them not and they were
many of them were detained hundreds were
detained I think there's still detainees
without charging you know and that is
just a fundamental
violation of Human Rights there is no
question about it so you know one of the
imperfections what can I say
it's a bad one but at least there's some
discourse I mean there is some
discussion about it which is good last
question to keep the focus here on
terrorism for a second and and basically
my my concern is why in the world aren't
Democrats media disaffected Republicans
whatever going after bush in terms of
his strong suit namely terrorism simply
saying mr. president you talked about
cut and run 9/11 are words out of your
mouth every five minutes you are the one
who cut and run with respect to Osama
bin Laden still uncaught with respect to
al Qaeda with respect to the Taliban for
the first three months he pursued them
properly and then he completely forgot
about it
they only reappear conveniently in
osama's videotape usually just before an
election to hype the polls and so on and
my concern is this 9/11 comes out of his
mouth every five minutes words put in by
karl rove every single speech by bush
cheney in the very same sentence
combines the words terrorism afghanistan
and iraq one has nothing whatsoever to
do with another with the other he
completely cut and run turn tail ran
away from 9/11 diverted all the
resources to iraq yeah right now as we
speak by better than a ten to one ratio
the budget and the work force power is
in Iraq over Afghanistan he uses
Afghanistan he's naive to the fact that
Ally bonds all over the world and why
aren't these people promoting that and
you know attacking him in terms of his
strong suit and you know all this
hypocrisy about becoming hysterical over
9/11 you
living in a pre 9/11 world and so I
agree I agree absolutely and I can't
understand at this point why the
Democrats are not more unified on this I
think that the it's partly because some
of the solutions the Democrats have
floated over the years in in during
elections and so on have not seemed to
succeed for example John Kerry talking
about law enforcement as being the
leading edge of our anti-terror campaign
and he was ridiculed for it in in the Oh
for presidential election again the
London situation seems to verify what he
was talking about but law enforcement is
kind of a you know it's it's not a sexy
way of talking about it
and I think there's also a certain
amount of disagreement within the
Democratic Party but as I said earlier
and I agree with you absolutely on this
that the that the actions of Bush
particularly with respect to Afghanistan
and even more so in Iraq and I think now
with their I think puzzling and
indefensible non-action with respect to
Israel and Lebanon in the first weeks of
the war have just created many many more
people who are prone to to violent
action not thousands but it doesn't take
thousands it just takes a few anyway
thank you again I'll be signing books if
you want
jaunty r men on his book 100 ways
America is screwing up the world he's
executive director of MIT Center for
Internet